hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my YouTube viewers al who
was asking about an mba program and if
it's worth it or not so wrote in saying
hey I was going to ask you about
spending over a hundred thousand dollars
on an mba program from a reputable
school is it worth it
it's distantly speaking I know a
difference from person to person thanks
al
so i'lll does differ from person to
person I can only share what my
experience is and hopefully that helps
you so I didn't get an MBA program I
went to University of Toronto for
undergraduate degree and I decided not
to go get an MBA mostly because I was
already running my business and I
thought I'd get a lot more value from
being in my business again in the
hands-on experience then spend another
couple years at school and working out
of textbooks so that was my own personal
decision I think it depends on what your
background is I came from a business
school background and I was already
running businesses before I went to
university so I had a lot of the
fundamentals in place already I knew a
lot of the concepts before starting my
company if you're coming from an arts
program or science program or computer
program and you may not know some of the
business fundamentals then it could be
more valuable for you if you're going to
go get a job then it definitely is a lot
more value for you than it is for being
an entrepreneur because a lot of
companies are looking for people who
have that MBA kind of separates you from
everybody else and it's almost expected
now that you would go get an MBA to keep
moving up one of the biggest benefits
that I find from an MBA program is being
able to make some good connections so
depending on what your business is going
to be doing if you plan on selling to
big companies down the line all the
people who you go to school with most of
them will end up going to work at big
companies and they'll be moving up in
the ranks and you'll have contacts and
friends to be able to talk business with
potentially sell to down the line so you
can make a lot of great connections from
joining an MBA program that you might
want to think about as well so those are
on my personal thoughts I'd like to turn
it over to Jeff Ogden a friend of mine
from
new customers to get his perspective as
well
so the question was asked is spending
$100,000 for an MBA really worth it
well my and actually I don't have an MBA
I decided not to get one but I really
think the answer is a qualified maybe
because there's really three things you
get from an MBA you get knowledge so
you've got two years of learning from
some excellent professors you've got
skills that you're going to develop over
that time and you've got networking
because you're the alumni network has a
lot of value in addition there's an
intangible value that is a prestige that
comes from a prestigious school so you
know there are benefits that come from
it however it's a big expense and the
thing you've got you got to say is can I
get that on my own for instance I don't
have an MBA but I have a winter
prestigious undergrad school Notre Dame
I accumulated massive amounts of skills
over the 30 years since I've graduated a
tree accumulated tremendous knowledge in
fact my content is taught in the MBA
program there and I don't have an MBA so
can you do it without spending a hundred
thousand dollars yes you can but it
takes a long time so if you've got the
money and you want to move fast
get your MBA but if you're tight on
money and you don't owe and you're not
in a huge rush then do do it on your own
you don't need to go to school I hope
that helps so while I hope that was
useful hope my thoughts were helpful and
Jeff's thoughts as well if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below and I also love to hear
thoughts on getting an MBA program if
you want to leave a comment under the
video and stay tuned for next episode